viruses from influenza to the common
cold we've all had experiences with
these nasty diseases they're easy to
catch quickly transferring from one host
to another through proximity or physical
contact this also means that viruses are
easily spread and if the number of
infected grows beyond what is treatable
it can [ __ ] the entire world's health
infrastructure overrun hospitals
behavioral mandates and constant death
are all elements of a worldwide pandemic
it's no wonder why zombie outbreaks and
lab-grown diseases are such common
premises for horror movies and video
games diseases are downright scary and
it's most likely because the world has
been overtaken by disease on multiple
occasions that makes them so frightening
the bubonic plague the great influenza
pandemic and even the kovid 19 pandemic
are all events that have wiped out
significant portions of humanity and if
left unchecked a viral disease might be
able to wipe out every last one of us
sure you can take measures to keep
yourself safe but who's to say a
mutation isn't out of the question a
disease altering its own biology to
overcome resistance and continue its
spread could be a germophobe's nightmare
and have serious consequences for the
entire world of course we're still
talking about ordinary diseases but what
about when the virus is anything but
normal what if it falls under the
umbrella that could be termed anomalous
enter the scp foundation for them
anomalous viruses are some of the
hardest to secure contain and protect
the world from it's not hard to imagine
why either containing viruses often
involves the spread of safety
precautions and information sometimes
distributions of vaccines and medicine
basically to stop a virus people need to
first know what they're dealing with
when you're operating under the veil of
secrecy that the foundation has to
maintain your options for information
dispersal become a lot more complicated
of course by nature of being anomalous
the diseases the foundation has to deal
with are a lot stranger and definitely
more dangerous than just another strain
of the flu perhaps you're already
familiar with scp-008
the infectious disease codenamed the
zombie plague that shuts down a victim's
body and decays it heavily but the scp
foundation's russian database has a
deadly virus of its own scp-1007-ru
is also known as the nicha virus it's
nicknamed after the famous german
philosopher who coined the term god is
dead and explored themes of nihilism an
ideology that delves into the
meaninglessness of life the universe and
humanity's existence if that doesn't
clue you in that this anomaly is
horrifying then just wait until we dive
into the file itself
scp-1007-ru is given its viral and
infectious nature kept in a high
security containment chamber intended to
seal the anomaly away from the world the
chamber is outfitted with a triple
airlock system that prevents accidental
leakage and unwanted access entry into
scp-1007-ru's containment chamber comes
with its own set of special containment
procedures researchers must outfit
themselves in an insulated protective
suit that allows no material from inside
the chamber to make contact with their
body once their work with
scp-1007-ru is finished they must take a
sterilizing shower to watch any
potentially lingering harmful particles
from their body and if that's not enough
they're forced into a six-hour
quarantine isolated from the rest of the
foundation until their superiors are
absolutely sure that they don't exhibit
signs of infection if personnel are by
chance contaminated after contact with
scp-1007-ru
the foundation takes their best
interests into account and immediately
euthanizes them followed by a cremation
of their remains to make sure all
biological material is destroyed
entirely as harmful infectious agents
may still persist on skin tissue and
inside the body long after death has
occurred yes the containment procedures
for scp-1007-ru
is immediate termination of a valuable
foundation employee those don't grow on
trees either and the foundation
definitely does not resort to this
option very often but this only
demonstrates the severe threat that
scp-1007-ru poses to the foundation's
integrity perhaps losing one employee is
better than the innumerable deaths
caused by a full-scale outbreak of the
anomaly the area surrounding
scp-1007-ru's containment chamber
located in a facility kept inside the
larger foundation grouping of zone zero
seven is also kept free of contamination
by a high temperature sterilization
process
as a final security measure to keep
scp-1007-ru's containment as safe as it
can possibly be since
scp-1007-a
is transmitted like most contagious
viral diseases via airborne physical and
blood contact the foundation has made
sure their containment procedures are as
safe and tightly designed as possible
since anyone who comes into contact with
the anomaly is a carrier of it all of
the precaution is understandably
necessary but what is scp-1007-ru
aside from a deadly infectious disease
what makes it anomalous and separates it
from an ordinary virus
scp-1007-ru specifically involves a
multi-step mutation of neurons if you
don't already know neurons are cells
that transmit and receive nerve impulses
throughout our bodies neurons respond to
stimuli sensations like touch sound
light and information from other cells
they're an essential part of our bodies
and a necessary component for cells to
communicate with one another
but most importantly neurons help us
feel pain when
scp-1007-ru infects a subject it changes
their neurons over time to allow them to
feel an increased threshold of pain
tolerance
meaning that the victim can feel a more
intense amount of pain before succumbing
to death or losing consciousness that
almost sounds beneficial right if
everyone had an increased pain tolerance
things like minor cuts or falling off
your chair would barely register as
harmful but
scp-1007-ru has a disadvantageous
trade-off that comes with its multi-step
nature as the virus mutates and changes
it does so in steps but before each
stage of cell mutation occurs the victim
experiences enough pain to completely
overwhelm their pain tolerance threshold
scp-1007-ru's initial incubation period
lasts two to four hours after which the
virus will make its way through the
central nervous system and to the brain
the victim experiences severe pain in
line with their ordinary pain threshold
and promptly loses consciousness after
they regain consciousness the true
horrors of
scp-1007-ru commence and the anomaly
begins to mutate their neurons and alter
their existing pain thresholds to
accommodate more stimuli scp-1007-ru
seems to have an indefinite number of
stages if the victim can handle the pain
the infection will persist and the
neutrons will continue to mutate until
they're unable to suffer anymore and die
from the disease technically speaking
the virus is infinite and will go on
until death occurs but foundation
research has found that human subjects
have only been able to reach at most the
anomalies sixth stage after which they
die not a single test subject has
persisted to the seventh iteration of
the virus as it's believed to be too
much pain for the human body to handle
but if a subject did reach these
impossible pain thresholds they most
likely wouldn't last much longer
curiously when the foundation
experimented with
scp-1007-ru on a rat it survived nine
stages into the anomaly however the pain
was too much for the researchers to bear
observing and the decision was made to
put the poor creature out of its misery
shortly after each stage follows a
similar pattern allowing it to be
predictably catalogued and measured
across all test subjects first the
subject will experience severe pain just
below their current pain tolerance
threshold after 36 hours the pain will
intensify growing larger and more
harmful for the victim until they
finally lose consciousness a few minutes
later when the subject has fully
regained consciousness the next stage
begins and the process repeats itself
only this time the pain threshold is
increased over time this process will
continue to repeat itself and grow more
deadly until the subject expires dying
from severe levels of pain beyond any of
our comprehension what makes the disease
even worse to contract is that this pain
is unable to be suppressed the
foundation has certainly tried from
analogy sex to tranquilizers and surely
some memetic agents designed to reduce
painful sensations but nothing has had
any effect on an individual infected by
scp-1007-ru
they are forced to endure the pain
without any reprieve for a full 36 hours
before passing out they can't even lose
consciousness before the stage ends
meaning that the only break from
scp-1007-ru
is the few short minutes in between
stages all before the process repeats
itself again and again
interestingly the inactive period
between stages labeled the questions
period seems to increase exponentially
as time goes on the first period ranges
from 48 to 108 hours where the subject
feels completely ordinary before the
next active stage occurs and their pain
tolerance is increased the foundation
typically does not like to prolong the
pain of its test subjects beyond what's
absolutely necessary to understand all
elements of an anomaly the moral issues
that resulted from
scp-1007-ru's research were addressed in
a statement by overseer 05-4
which read human experiments are
performed only with the explicit
permission of the overseer council any
requests for experiments in which a
subject would have to reach the sixth
stage are rejected automatically first
try to imagine such pain but regardless
experiments involving
scp-1007-ru have been performed for the
purposes of gaining all of this
information and the foundation kept
recorded transcripts of some of them one
interview which was held two hours 12
minutes after the first exposure to the
virus and then held again at 2 hours and
17 minutes following infection involved
in interaction between dr lungan and an
unfortunate patient first the patient
felt fine and asked if the researcher
had infected them with something when
asked to describe how they felt they
exclaimed that they felt fine and had
been sitting there for two hours feeling
normal then the virus took root and a
howling scream filled the room the
patient began to sob and scream feeling
pain unlike anything else they had felt
before pain they didn't know they were
capable of feeling they called for dr
lungin to stop the experiment asking why
this was happening to them but lungin's
assistant called for the subject to be
restrained and locked up as the pain
increased they became desperate
confessing to the crimes they had
committed prior to being imprisoned and
drafted as a foundation d-class
personnel and begging the foundation to
stop but even if the foundation wanted
to they couldn't there was nothing they
could do but watch adhering to the
procedure dr lungen calmly told the
subject to relax themselves and asked
where they were feeling the pain but the
subject continued to scream barely able
to get the words out their head skin
heart stomach bones and teeth every last
bit of their body was overwhelmed with
nothing but pure pain the subject begged
and pleaded and struggled for hours
until they eventually lost consciousness
upon coming to the subject asked what
had happened to which dr longin's
assistant junior researcher cosmoff
responded that he'll certainly remember
in two days dr longin was rightfully
mortified by what he witnessed on that
day and protested further
experimentation with scp-1000
bungan appeared before the overseer
council and advocated for the
destruction of the virus but the o5s
were unable to accommodate his request
as they had already severely limited the
experiments and were unsure of how to
take measures to eradicate the virus
completely lungin withdrew from the
scp-1007-ru research project and the
position of research head was given to
his assistant junior researcher cosmoth
despite kosmov's inexperience and
sadistic tendencies to prolong and
observe experiences lungin was let go
however kosmov's psychological
evaluation was still within the lines of
what the foundation considered
acceptable and he was given permission
to have complete control over all
scp-1007-ru research materials the file
ends with a single note written by
kosmov shortly after his promotion to
research head permission has been
granted for experiments involving humans
up to stage 9 ms cosmov now go check out
scp-610 the flesh that hates and scp-500
panacea for more anomalous diseases and
cures